for a lot of you November means  Thanksgiving and what could you be more  thankful for than free games I'm Tony  this is a GameSpot news update and this  is your PlayStation Plus November lineup  ps4 owners are getting top-down shooter  the deadly tower of monsters and the  indie hit everybody's gone to the  rapture the ps3 is getting the cutesy  RPG costume quest to and rally racing  game dirt 3 PS Vita players can take on  stunts challenges in pumped BMX Plus and  a word based adventure in letter quest  remastered and thanks to cross play you  can also play both of those games on  your ps4 and try Pumped BMX plus on ps3  any of those sound good to you the new  PlayStation Plus games will be available  Tuesday November 1st you have until then  to grab October's games including  Resident Evil HD and transformers  devastation to keep up with all the  latest from PlayStation you're already  in the right place  you